hello everyone and welcome to round
eight of the 1970 intra zonal tournament
in Palma de Majorca
it's Renato naranja versus Robert James
Fisher or Bobby Fischer now you all seen
in round 7 until up until round 7 Bobby
had that amazing streak streak of five
victories and then he ran into a wall
called Milan Mutulu which were he from a
worse position he was managed to hold to
a draw and now he has the black feet a
black pieces against a grandmaster from
the Philippines they're not on araña
now we do have a nice photo not of this
match up but I'm sure you'll enjoy it
here a treat a three gentlemen the photo
was taken by Olympia working from
Singapore and from left to right there
there is Renato naranja and then in the
middle we have our mystery person who we
will use for our photo challenge and to
the right Florencio compa - and it's
very interesting if you've been a
subscriber on this channel for quite
some time now you should be able to
recognize the person in the middle if
not you know check out the comment
section I'm sure some of you will know
who he is
as we've seen a very nice game he played
against international master Jeremy
Stillman where he brought a nice a nice
big jar of honey to the game but if you
haven't checked it out it's also a very
nice story so the first thing you will
see in the description below will be a
link to that game I covered so you know
you can enjoy that as well so let's
check out the game Renato not on how
with the white pieces against Bobby
Fischer let's see how the game goes and
this game will perfectly illustrate what
kind of a guy Bobby Fischer was so let's
check it out
c4 c5 let me just take care of that so
the symmetrical variation of the English
Knight c3 Bobby goes for g6 Knight to f3
Bishop to g7 d4 Bobby captures C capture
son d4 Knight captors on d4 hand Knight
to c6 III Knight to f6 Bobby keeps on
developing mr. P - we have castles
castles and now Knight captures on b4
and although he captures on d4 I don't
know seems like an automatic to me
pretty sure I would play this
you know or every time we have Queen
characters on d4 here obviously a
prepared line we have d6 and now comes
Queen to h4 Bishop to e6 and now comes
Rock to d1 Queen to b6 by Fischer kind
of preventing that Bishop from c1 from
developing as the bb2 point is under
attack
so rook to be one defending the b2 point
but also getting the rook out of this
nasty g7 a one diagonal and now Queen to
c5
so Fischer is playing a lot of moves
with his Queen and he is kind of
provoking this beast before move which
is played in the game before we have
Queen to f5 now again which tempo is the
rook and B one is under attack now
efore attacking Fischer's Queen and now
Fischer plays Queen to e5 now so a lot
of moves with the Queen but all of it
all of them are with tempo so not really
losing anything here the knight on c3 is
under attack
okay rook to b3 defending and now
Fischer has to be really careful if
you're not careful you play something
like rook c8 the attack of the c4 pawn
and then f4 loses the game immediately
although you don't lose the Queen you
can defend with the g5 it kind of does
attack White Queen as well but even here
you will lose the the night here and
after black recaptures 95 our wife will
be able to enjoy his extra piece so you
have to do something about this Queen
being stuck on e5 so Bishop to d7
Fischer makes room for the Queen on e6 F
for attacking the Queen Queen to e6 and
now while you can you know keep on keep
on developing maybe may be preparing
here Renate raha goes immediately for f5
and I spawn sacrifice but again Fischer
will have to defend like in the previous
game we have G characters on f5 pawn
captures on f5 and now Queen captures on
f5 and Bishop to g5 now so what do you
do here you have to be very careful
Bishop to d3 is coming with an attack on
the Queen and the h7 point Bishop to g5
is attacking the only defender of the h7
point so you have to
you have to do something here Fischer
plays h6 he wants to give back the pond
- you know stop the attack and well here
probably the best idea is Bishop to a4
keep everything on the board keep the
pressure going 95 is coming this rook
can come to g3 Bishop can come to d3 a
lot of attacking ideas here foreigner
aha but he takes the easy way out and he
wraps at the point Bishop captures on h6
and here Queen to h7 Bishop to g5 ah he
offers a trade of Queen's Queen captures
the Bishop captures on h4 and now Bishop
to e6 so material is now equal and now
now the game continues
we have Bishop captures on f6 and here a
very important moment in the game
because now they're not on raha is an
international master and he did win the
zonal tournament to qualify for this
intro zonal tournament but mmm he's not
really expecting to qualify for the
candidates as he's not doing so great in
the tournament so far so this is an
excellent move from his perspective but
it's not an easy decision from bobbies
perspective of course you have to play
Bishop captures on f6 here and if Bishop
captures the problem is that white can
force a draw with Knight d5 attacking
the bishop if you if you mess up black's
pawn structure then you know white will
be even better and after Bishop captures
you don't even have to capture back the
bishop you can simply play rook g3 check
and here you can simply continue
checking and it will be a draw by
repetition eventually so after this
Bishop captures on f6 move amazingly
Fischer place he captures on f6 so he
ruins his pawn structure and purpose
allows
Renato to capture this d6 pawn and while
this is well this is a terrible pins
decision for black and that's the kind
of guy Bobby Fischer was so and it's
very interesting you don't have to win
the intra zonal tournament to actually
qualify for the for the candidates I
mean you have to be in the in the top
six six content six contenders so even
though Fischer is currently in
lead and a draw in this game wouldn't
really hurt him like in the least
because he will he will definitely
qualify in the top six six containers
but no he will rather risk losing and go
for a full point then accepting a draw
here so okay a very interesting turn of
events
nice to d5 and Naha doesn't go for the
DS exponent because after rope captures
you can play rook c8 attack the c4 pawn
there's no real good way to defend it as
you can't move the pond the rook on v3
will be hanging from the bishop so nice
to d5 first rook F to d8 and now comes
Luke to f3 attacking the f6 bond Fischer
goes King f8 now comes Knight captures
on f6 and now rook a to c8 and here the
c4 pawn is under attack and definitely
if you if you want to keep the edge here
with the white pieces you have to go 95
you have to protect your c4 pawn and
this this is what you want to do if you
want to push for something more than the
draw here but again no matter how takes
the easy way out and after Fischer's
root kc8 he goes 492 h6 check Fischer
moves the King back we have knight back
to f6 and now Fischer captures Bishop
captures rook captures and now Bishop
captures on c4 grabbing that extra pawn
Bishop captures rook captures rook
captures and d6 route captors and e6
rook captures and e6 and now Fischer
capture some before rook captures than
before and it's three points against
three points both both both sides have
to point islands and now the game
continues we're rook to d2 now bringing
the route back to the second rank not
allowing the a two point to get under
attack from b2 Fisher pushes b5 we have
king of two roped away for now King to
e3
King g17 d3 rook to a3 check King moves
a5 we have King to c5 and now before so
it's a pretty it's a pretty standard
trade off there's no way for for white
endanger these pawns in any way the rock
is guarding and da 5.05 point is
guarding the b4 pawn and
this rock is stuck guarding the a tube
born so neither side can really make
progress here King beef I was played
then comes f5 from Fisher g3 we have
king of six rook to e2 King to g5 rook
to F to king g6 roof to d2 King f7
rookie to King to f6 King to see for
King to g5 King to b5 King to g4 we have
rook to F to King comes to h3 and now
well you can definitely make a mistake
here Fischer offers Fischer offers white
one one last chance to blunder the game
away for example if you capture on f5
and allow black to capture then of
course you would lose this game after
Luke captures and rook captures here
although the material is equally - it
will be this will be winning for black
for example rook h5 check King attacks
rook rook at the rook checks king king
here now comes g4 and now King to eat -
of course you don't want to push b3 here
because rock h3 would pick up the b2
pawn but after king e to the B pawn is
simply much faster than the Jeep on here
rook has the block but then comes rook
to a3 and after rook moves then B 3 will
be simply winning rook will block King
has to come protect the pawn after he
moves a 4 we have g4 g5 now comes Luke
a1 g6 rook to g1 and after King a5 let's
say King C - and now the b3 pawn will be
escorted rook checks King hides King
captures and now comes rook captures and
after let's say you attack this comes
with check King moves and now rock h4
you will eliminate White's a white flash
pawn and then this point will be winning
as the White King is completely cut off
but here Renato naranja doesn't wander
the game way he moves away of rook to d2
and here he shows that he will simply
keep on moving the rook back and forth
and there is no way to push here for
anything so a very interesting game from
round 8 Renato Naha vs. Bobby Fischer
yet another game Bobby Fischer has to
defend he gets an extra pawn but it's a
very difficult position and
the aeronaut on the run have had two
opportunities to push for something more
than a draw but he's not having the
greatest tournament so far and you know
no one has defeated Bobby Fischer just
yet he defeated five extremely strong
grandmasters in a row so are you not on
a run how perhaps didn't want to push
his luck and you know if you if you make
one one better moved and you're gonna
throw the whole game away so why not
take a draw against the highest rated
player in the world so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you're enjoying the coverage so far like
I said do check out the game by this
fellow in the middle at the end a very
nice story about the honey jar I would
like to thank Danny McCullough John
cutsie as David saw as Nuria Blanco
Rodriguez and Eric Barak Barossa for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
I think all for watching and I will see
you soon
most likely with game number 9 from this
very nice 1970 inter-zonal tournament in
Palma de Majorca but perhaps if some
craziness arises in the bill chess
festival maybe we'll cover some games
from there so thank you all and I will
see you soon